in what could be a crucial break federal
investigators searched the home of a
person of interest in the nashville
christmas bond the role of the man
identified as 63-year-old anthony quinn
warner is not yet
clear the top prosecutor in the case has
his own name for whoever is responsible
this this ultimate scrooge who on
christmas morning instead of spreading
joy and cheer decided to spread
devastation and destruction
u.s authorities pursuing more than 500
tips and leads
expressed confidence after finding what
they believe to be human remains near
the site of the explosion
saying there is no manhunt and no risk
of a follow-up attack
at this point we don't have any
indication that we are looking for
another subject but
again there's uh 500 leads we're running
through so there's all kinds of
individuals we're looking for
i am fairly confident we'll be able to
identify an individual or ascertain what
has occurred
those remains found at the scene might
belong to a bomber who was killed in the
attack
but it is unclear if anyone was inside
the recreational vehicle when it
detonated
block after block of the world's country
music capital were damaged
my windows completely caved into my
apartment complex
and uh it woke me up immediately
and next thing you know all we're
hearing is screams and
and the sirens going off the explosion
was heard
miles away
turning restaurants and live music
venues to rubble
and disabling mobile phone networks the
explosion outside of an att
transmission center was apparently aimed
at property not
people it happened in the pre-dawn hours
before
tourists would have been filling up this
part of town
and before it exploded the recreational
vehicle broadcast a warning for people
around it
to evacuate
six police officers ran toward the
danger clearing out residents
just before an explosion that arrived
before the bomb squad
i'm grateful to the team behind us
and nashville's depending on them to do
a great job
and our resolve as a community to both
rebuild second
and to find the culprit is
is very great that city is now piecing
itself
back together as hundreds of
investigators pour over the scene of a
christmas day bombing for clues as to
who was behind it
how they did it and why john hendren
al jazeera nashville tennessee